I mostly get actioned well know where I
get I get the crap beat out of me a
number of times
hi I'm the hero of Times Square I'm
Lorraine I'm getting you a scarf soon
and I'm like and this is Earth's
Mightiest show where we talk about all
the most Jessica Jones stuff in the
Marvel Universe
because Marvel's Jessica Jones season 3
is almost here add it to your Netflix
queue now so that you can stream all 13
episodes when they drop on June 14th
only on Netflix plus there will be a lot
more about season 3 on the show today
so gird your loins oh my lord well you
is this week and boy it's always a blast
oh my goodness lots of big news about
some upcoming Marvel games including
Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 the black
order coming to Nintendo's switch July
19th and of course there's Marvel's
Avengers very excited for this game
coming to PlayStation 4 Xbox one stadia
and PC so if you guys are not yet
familiar with III get on it it's the
Electronic Entertainment Expo yes
they're your 3ds in e3 yes it's a huge
game convention in LA where you can see
new games play new games see all types
of new stuff technology it's a blast
yeah our own agent M actually was there
aka Ryan panelist he was on the scene
and he has all of the best of e3
oh I'm game pack what's yeah hey y'all
it is the most wonderful time of the
year III in LA it's video game of heaven
I'm so excited it's been a wonderful
time I saw so much Marvel's Avengers
Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 the black
order there's so much fun stuff I got to
share with you my favorite Marvel
moments of e3 let's check them out
[Music]
we kicked off III 2019 in the biggest
way possible with Marvel's Avengers
revealing the game to the world story
characters actor settings some highs
some lows some tears so much more and
I'm super hyped for the game and for e3
2019 but I'm not the only one hyped for
Marvel's Avengers this week if we were
hyped for the reveal oh boy oh boy we
got so much more here on the show floor
at e3 there is a giant Marvel's Avengers
booth and it is loaded with swag we've
got lanyards and dossiers it's got
costumes for the five core Avengers that
you can check out season here put it all
leads who actually get in to see about
thirty minutes of gameplay for Marvel's
Avengers and it is mind-blowing we went
inside we saw a lot of cool stuff share
with you what we can oh man but if you
think this is it no we got so much more
to see and do here at e3 let's check it
out Nintendo's booth has been swamped
throughout III 2019 but we got in here
super early to get exclusive access to
play Marvel Ultimate Alliance through
the Black Order guys it's so much fun
[Music]
hell yes you guys you saw so much fun
what an amazing III now remember
Marvel's Avengers comes out May 15 2020
make sure you preorder it for ps4 xbox
pc or stadia and of course Marvel
Ultimate Alliance 3 the black order
comes out July 19th on Nintendo switch I
can't wait and actually I got some more
time I'm gonna go play some games I'll
see you soon
man so jealous we got to go with so much
fun I gotta get all I'm getting all the
games yeah my thumb's are twitchy okay
we are not here to play games or at
least not to just play games that's
rolling you some of that but let's talk
about marbles Jessica Jones season 3 yes
oh so much happened with Jessica her mom
resurfacing Trish exploring what it's
like to have powers of her own kind of
sorta and of course the dromedary
battling ALS yeah and that's just where
we're gonna pick up season I mean see
that too was jam-packed and so emotional
so I'm really excited to see what
happened yes they were put through the
ringer of emotion and trials in
tribulations coming out looking better
and worse who knows it because we don't
see the threes coming listen I really
love they build out that whole world
that season it was really really yeah
well you know speaking of being immersed
in Jessica's world I got to tour the set
whoa oh that's nice let's take a look
around yeah hey marmalades I am here on
the set of Marvel's Jessica Jones season
3 and I'm actually on a soundstage in
Brooklyn New York a lot of people might
not realize that a lot of the sets are
actually built completely originally
here in a studio and I'm gonna take you
inside for a little set to her come on
and now I am on the set this is
Jessica's elevator of course it's not an
elevator in real life because there's a
solid floor underneath us but you might
remember a lot of dramatic moments and
awkward moments shared in this elevator
you know go to a movie sometime
this is Malcolm's apartment mmm I don't
think he's home he's probably
entertaining a lady friend but this is
of course Jessica Jones's assistant well
on-again off-again on-again off-again
on-again off it's complicated but let's
see if Jessica's home here we are in
Jessica Jones's bedroom there have been
a lot of special moments in this room
and a lot of drama
not only did sparks fly between Jessica
and Luke Cage this is also the place
where Luke was brought when he had a
traumatic brain injury and Claire temple
had to save his life there also of
course were sparks between her and Oscar
her super but there was also a beautiful
moment that she shared with her mom
were they laid right here and slept for
the first time together in 17 years and
one of my favorite things about being in
this room is I definitely saw some
coconut body wash over there so now we
all know what Jessica Jones smells like
let's see what else I can find
and here we are in Jessica's kitchen
okay she's not necessarily the best cook
but she does have dishes and I mean I do
sort of love this set because it's all
built like a real Coldwater tenement in
the old days
you've got exposed pipes and all kinds
of fun funky little details right down
to it a bunch of leftover coffee in the
sink
I mean relatable let's see what else and
here we are in Jessica's living room and
by living room I mean this is how she
makes her living for alias
investigations this is where she does
all of her research whether it's finding
out where kilgrave has been hiding or
what IgH is up to and how she got her
superpowers and it looks like it's been
through some rough times with these
gouges but you know when she's looking
for clues
there's only one way you can really
string together a theory and that's why
putting them all up on the board I guess
sometimes that can be frustrating if
this big punch hole and then this board
is to tell us anything but I'm gonna be
looking for even more clues about
Marvel's Jessica Jones Season three you
should check it out streaming only on
Netflix and for now I'm just gonna kind
of hang out with Jess I'm gonna see if
she comes home later bye bye
well I thought that was an apartment
building that's a set yeah isn't that
crazy it's a whole floor of an apartment
just lives there Malcolm lives there
it's like it feels like home yeah is it
home did you move in I did I live there
yeah how much is the rent I I'm
squatting water oh yeah listen there's a
lot more to come this season including a
new character that will be a very
interesting foil for Jessica yeah in
fact I caught up with that mysterious
character played by the incredibly fun
Benjamin Walker when I was hanging out
at Jessica's place Oh dope here it is I
am hanging out here on the set of
Marvel's Jessica Jones season 3 and look
who I found it's Ben Walker hello hello
hello hello so what can you tell us
about your character Eric Sheldon not a
lot but enough to keep him interesting
he is a blackmailer a gambler a drinker
he has moved to New York from the south
for some family and personal reasons and
he's kind of found himself in hot water
largely because of his own behavior
right so that's on that's on Eric
well you meet Eric early when he is
drunk in trouble in pain and desperate
that's perfect for Jessica that's like
her whole thing right exactly it's kind
of star-crossed lovers and he needs her
help great so that's how we meet Eric
but he has a lot to offer and I think
Jessica quickly realizes that now you
get to of course play opposite Krysten
Ritter sure what has it been like
working with Kristen she's great she's a
pro and on camera and off camera she
directed an episode so so that's been
incredibly positive because you know
this is my first kind of long-form
television
and to kind of have her holding my hand
through it has been really great kind of
okay and she whispers it delicately like
that oh no no Kristin is very loud and
very straight for you don't do it like
that what can you tell us about some of
the action that we might see for this
season because we know Jessica can jump
out of windows and do some pretty cool
stunts will you get in on any action I I
mostly get actioned well no well I get I
get the crap beat out of me a number of
times part of what's interesting about
Eric and to this question is that he
starts his kind of a mess up a screw up
and through the course of it he learns
to defend himself in to fight for the
right so in the beginning he's kind of
getting his what and by the end he
learns that maybe he can flip that well
I can't wait to see it I can't wait for
you guys to see it thank you so much for
talking with us
my pleasure be sure to watch Marvel's
Jessica Jones season three streaming
only on Netflix well Benjen what a guy
can't we just see how his character
interact Jessica this season here movie
to stream all episodes of the new season
of Marvel's Jessica Jones tomorrow June
14th as well as seasons 1 & 2 now
streaming only on Netflix yeah that's
right I love just so much can wait for
this new season oh and tell us what you
love most about Jessica Jones and use
that hashtag
Earth's Mightiest show see you next time
I'm Lorraine and I'm Langston this is
Marvel your universe
thanks for watching
Earth's Mightiest show if you like this
like says leave us a comment and
subscribe to the Marvel channel or click
the box over there to watch our last
episode so uh Langston's what would you
do with Jessica Jones powers well I
would just leap on the roofs